phil es gracias a ustedes y washington
está contemplando dejar de importar
petróleo ruso está esa posibilidad
directamente relacionada con la visita a
venezuela un país petrolero pero
sancionado
si absolutamente porque tenemos que
recordar que washington no tiene
relaciones diplomáticas con el gobierno
nicolás maduro de hecho reconoce a juan
guaidó líder de la oposición como
presidente venezuela entonces
evidentemente este tipo de visita es muy
sorprendente y viene precisamente en el
contexto de la crisis energética mundial
o la potencial crisis en el ejercicio
mundial estaba unido está preocupada
preocupado de que los precios del
petróleo suban y necesita suplir o
reemplazar el petróleo ruso en caso de
que deje de importarlo venezuela es una
posible fuente de ese petróleo y
mientras tanto como sabemos rusia es el
segundo mayor proveedor de petróleo
mundial además de ser uno de los
principales exportadores de gas natural
en qué consistiría un eventual acuerdo
con venezuela y que tanto ayudaría a
paliar la crisis
ahí es donde empieza a complicarse el
asunto porque si fuera simplemente la
cuestión energética tenemos que tomar en
cuenta que la industria petrolera
venezolana está en el suelo está en el
piso hace unos años venezuela produce
unos 3 millones de barriles diarios
ahora produce menos de un millón y es
muy difícil que ese esa cifra suba
inmediatamente por otro lado está la
cuestión política porque eeuu mantiene
sanciones contra venezuela
y están condicionadas esas sanciones o
su levantamiento a un acuerdo político
que en este momento no existe y que
tendría que pasar en teoría por un
acuerdo entre el maduro y la oposición
estas conversaciones están suspendidas y
esta visita de buena manera
by pasea como dicen en venezuela es
decir pasa por encima del llamado
gobierno interino de why do que por
supuesto está un poco disgustado con el
asunto